hey 42 here nestled high up in the peaks
of the Himalayan mountain range in
northern India just on the border of
Tibet lies a mysterious lake called
Route few have traveled to this
remote body of water 5,000 meters above
sea level but a deadly surprise awaits
those who do embark upon the long trek
to visit this terrible thar bones lots
and lots of bones most of the year this
lake is frozen over but for one
effervescent month each year the ice
melts revealing the perilous scene at
the bottom of the murky water for this
lake bed is littered with hundreds of
hundreds of skeletal human remains human
bones can also be found scattered around
the lakes perimeter in alarming
quantities it has been estimated that
there are skeletons in and around
rubicund Lake of over 300 different
people the skeletons were first
discovered in the 19th century and they
remained the morbid curiosity for
hundreds of years but very few people
knew of their existence
until they were rediscovered during
World War Two in 1942 an investigation
began to discover where the 300 people
who perished at this remote mountain
lake came from and of course how they
died
the first and most obvious suspicion was
that they were the bodies of Japanese
soldiers who were trying to sneak their
way through India earlier on during the
war sneaky
Japanese and they died due to exposure
to the cold weather but after further
investigation it was deduced that the
skeletons were far too old to be from
the war disturbingly these skeletons
weren't just bones due to the dry and
extremely cold air they had been
preserved for an astonishingly long time
upon the skeletons investigators found
bits of flesh nails and hair and like a
scene from lost
they also found ancient wooden artifacts
leather shoes iron spearheads wooden
staves
Jewelry and an omnipotent man called
Jacob okay maybe not that last bit so
surely these remains can't be more than
a few decades old otherwise the flesh
would have decayed long blanc ago right
now this is where things get weird okay
things are already pretty weird but this
next discovery will blow your mind
samples of the skeletons and surrounding
artifacts were taken to Oxford
University in England where they
conducted radiocarbon dating to uncover
their age the remains dated back to 850
ad and they still had bits of flesh
attached how come I have to chuck out
food that starts to look dodgy if it's
been in my freezer for a couple of
months yet Mother Nature can preserve
parts of human bodies for almost 1,200
years no evidence of a settlement had
ever been found near the bodies so it's
assumes that all 300 people were
traveling at the time of their demise so
the obvious question is what killed them
starvation gangrene a landslide where
they attacked by Marauders was it aliens
perhaps but before you're so quick to
blame the aliens because I know you're
just dying to perhaps a local legend can
shed some light onto this astonishing
case according to the legends the once
king of carnage was travelling with his
pregnant wife on a pilgrimage as part of
the Nanda Devi Raj Ghat which is a large
pilgrimage that takes place in these
parts of India every 12 years being very
wealthy the king and his wife were
traveling with around 300 servants among
them were his personal dance troupe
because if you were travelling on a long
pilgrimage across the Himalayas you
would obviously want to take your dance
troupe in case you get bored or
something I need to get stranded
somewhere then you can always eat them
however the legend also tells of a freak
hailstorm
around that time when enormous balls of
ice pelted down from the sky one hit
from such a mighty hail stir
could quite easily cause death it could
certainly wipeout a group of 300
pilgrims high up in the mountains
especially when you consider that the
lake is a large open expanse with very
little shelter nearby in 2013
researchers examine the bodies in a bit
more detail and they found that every
person was killed by blows with a blunt
object to the head neck and shoulders
the large circular holes in the skeleton
skulls
seems to suggest that the sudden and
violent hailstorm legend could have been
responsible for the mysterious ninth
century human remains at rubikon lake
however this theory is the best that we
have so far but the mystery has
certainly not yet been proven and there
are many people who say that the
hailstorm idea is completely wrong the
bodies all had damage to their heads and
shoulders but absolutely no damage below
the shoulders hailstones aren't that
selective surely if 300 people were
killed by large balls of ice they would
have sustained injuries all over their
bodies some people would of course get
knocked over and pelted with hail on
their torso and legs and what about
their arms people most certainly would
have put their arms above their heads an
attempt to protect themselves from the
hailstones
yet no skeletons were found with
injuries to their arms hmm most
suspicious so then until we come up with
another more plausible solution to
explain this most mysterious conundrum
it will remain a mystery actually I
think it was aliens yep definitely
aliens thanks for watching let's take a
look at the actual physics behind Santa
Claus and find out if we shouldn't be so
quick to disbelieve in a very old
Christmas legend then you could be an
extraordinarily intelligent person
possibly even genius-level